today's guitar tip is brought to you by
arpeggiato my online music school
specializing in all things echo block
you can sign up for online lessons with
one of our expert teachers in
instruments like classical guitar
fingerstyle guitar ood loot and many
more so head over to arpeggiator.com to
learn more and don't forget to grab a
ticket to one of our online monthly
events
hey friends so in the last month or so a
variety of companies reached out to me
who make guitar supports and i've been
going back and forth between the ergo
play which is what i've been using for
more than a decade
the woodside lift the guitar lift among
others and i thought it'd be fun to make
a video where we try out a bunch of them
and talk about the pros and cons of each
and i do have a lot of different support
devices here so let's get started
throughout history guitars have been
held in countless ways but the main gist
is that we're trying to get this
instrument in such a place that both
hands can do what they need to do and
move in a healthy way without having you
know too crazy of contortions like that
famous picasso painting right
and of course a lot of its preference
you know how high should the guitar be
how far to the right how far to the left
how much rotation how about the tilt
there's so many angles to consider and
of course people throughout time have
their own preference and if you're not
too familiar with the classical guitar
at this point you might be thinking wait
a minute i've seen people just put the
guitar right on their thigh and play
what's wrong with that
while this is okay for you know folk
styles pop styles where you play a lot
of chords in first position on the
classical guitar we utilize the full
range of the instrument and it really
helps to have the instrument higher and
really slanted this seems to be the best
position to utilize the whole instrument
but the problem is when you put it here
how are we gonna hold it here right
this is the dilemma
[Music]
so before diving into the modern devices
let's first talk about what they did
perhaps in the renaissance
five hundred years ago at least um one
option that lewton's guitarist
discovered was to actually rest their
instrument against a table
and so you could sit next to a table
lean your instrument against it which
means that you have a little bit of
support from the table
and then we could
of course
play
there are some problems here though
we need a table that's the right height
for instance this table is too short
so you're kind of you know out of luck
if the table you happen to be
next to is in the right height so maybe
you bring one along with you and i don't
know that doesn't seem very portable so
perhaps we're not going to use today
the solution they found in the
renaissance embroil period
another historical solution which is
perhaps
more
convenient than bringing a table around
with you is the guitar strap
for some reason uh most guitarists today
use guitar straps but in the classical
guitar world
this seems like blasphemy and i don't
understand why
um
perhaps it's because segovia used a
footstool and so people think that
you're supposed to use a footstool but i
want to say to all the classical
guitarists out there or people getting
into classical guitar
a strap is a fantastic solution
you can head to any guitar store and get
a normal guitar strap and fit that to
your instrument another method that i
like to use on my early instruments is
just get a long ribbon
tie
the one end around your headstock don't
worry this doesn't damage
your instrument i'm just going to simply
tie
a knot
i'm going to try to make sure that the
the tuners are still
exposed so i can still tune
okay
and that is tied so this end is secure
it's not going anywhere i've kind of
laced it in between the tuners
and then on this side the only thing is
and i understand people are scared of
this
is to have a button installed so this is
my custom classical guitar which was
definitely pricey but i'm i'm going to
tell you now uh there is nothing wrong
with putting a button or an end pin
on your guitar if you have a
professional do this it doesn't harm the
instrument at all or devalue the
instrument it's perfectly safe so you
can have an end pin installed and then
what you can do is
tie a string in this case i actually
have a piece of gut tied around but you
can use nylon or whatever but the point
is to just make some sort of loop that's
not going to snap on you so a rubber
band is not going to do it but nylon or
in this case gut is really good you put
it around
the end pin and you let go and this is
so easy and convenient um from here we
can position the instrument exactly like
we want now it's very high it's at the
angle we like and
this is a really comfortable way of
playing
now two quick tips if you want to try a
strap on classical lazar the first is
really play around with the tightness of
the strap so if you feel constricted if
obviously it's too tight and if the
guitar is sagging down low obviously
it's too too loose so find the the right
tightness for you the other tip is
actually a nice trick i learned from
playing loots and that is
when you make the ribbon strap and i do
like the ribbon strap for this reason
let there be a lot of excess strap at
the end because then you sit
on that excess strap and this secures
the instrument so i can move my hands
wherever i want i can turn very freely
and
the instrument isn't going anywhere
which means i'm not using arm weight or
muscles to hold the instrument from
from falling i can just move my arms
freely play
play and this means i'm really efficient
and i'm doing what we really like to do
on the classical guitar which is to use
economy of motion and not waste energy
so it'd make me so happy to see more
classical guitarists taking advantage of
the option to use a strap so please do
so
[Music]
into the 19th century we start seeing
paintings of composers like francisco
targa and fernando soare using
footstools
and a footstool is i think today thought
of as maybe the orthodox way of holding
the classical guitar
it's pretty simple today you can buy a
footstool that's very adjustable
for the height
we put that to the ground we put our
left foot on top
of it which raises the leg and then the
guitar goes between our legs
and this little crook of the guitar
rests on your right your left thigh
and this indeed gets the guitar higher
and slanted and
obviously this works and you've seen a
lot of famous players of course segovia
john williams julian bream you name it
using this method and of course i did
this when i started playing classical
guitar for some years
but i was never comfortable and later i
realized the reason was because
my proportions are not really right for
a footstool i have a long torso compared
to the length of my legs and so my knee
has to be like
super high and i had to have the
footstool at maximum height and that was
still a little too low so i found that
so uncomfortable and indeed it also i
see in people it makes them twist their
body to the left uh so your hips are out
of alignment now your spine is twisted
uh i think it's safe to say that this is
not the most ergonomic way of holding
the guitar and i would actually
recommend guitarists
search out more healthier ways of
holding the instrument so personally i
wouldn't recommend the footstool however
i have to say that i have seen some
players who their their proportions are
right and they look so comfortable so if
it's right for you great but if you're
finding it uncomfortable perhaps there's
a better way
[Music]
now a few years into college after using
a footstool for a while i discovered the
ergo play which is a german
made support and this is a support that
uses suction cups on the side of the
instrument and when i discovered this
that really was a game changer for my
posture for my playing
and this is what i've been using now for
maybe 15 years
the way it works is very simple
you put the suction cups on the side of
your instrument and this actually holds
very well you can even hold your
instrument up from the suction cups
and it works just fine
that goes on your leg and that's what
divides the distance between the guitar
and your leg there's a bit of gripper
material
on the support so it doesn't slip away
and from there i can really get the
instrument right where i need let go of
my arms which is by the way the ultimate
test for me guitar supports should be
stable
and balanced in such a way that you can
let go
and move a little bit i can't move as
much as i can with a strap
but i can move and i don't have to hold
the instrument steady
so
this just put the instrument exactly
where i want it which is roughly at a 45
degree angle with the top of the guitar
at my
eye level and i'm not holding it there
with my arms so
this for me was
uh it sort of blew my mind
a lot of people are worried and they ask
me hey don't the suction cups hurt the
guitar
maybe they damage the finish or
something i've been using it for 15
years and i've never had that problem
they also make this clear static
electricity thing that you can put in
the in between and then the suction cups
are actually sticking to the static
electricity pad and that's what i have
on here now and it's it's been working
really well and what i love so much
about the ergo play is that it's just so
adjustable um this is the truster model
which is what i recommend there's some
other models which are less adjustable
for me this is the best it's about 70
bucks last time i got one
and you can really change all the angles
depending on how you change
the the little knobs you can change the
height
you can make it go more tilted uh you
can change the tilt which is very
important and then depending on where
you put the suction cups
i can change how far left or right the
instrument is by putting the suction
cups on to the left or farther to my
right
one of the things i don't like about the
ergo play is that the suction cups
sometimes come loose like one will come
off and that's happened to me at a
concert before and off suddenly you're
very
unstable um so i would recommend
changing the suction cups you can buy
these separately
anytime they seem to get a little worn
out very easy and cheap to replace these
you can also when the gripper wears out
you can replace that very cheap so
that's the only thing you have to change
the parts maybe every few years
but this is my tried and true support
and i would definitely go with that and
i think i would be
be happy with just this one
[Music]
now although i've been happy with the
ergo play for a long time in the last
month two different companies happened
to reach out to me
asking me if i wanted to try their
devices and i said
sure i'll give them a go and
this was my experience the first was
woodside guitars i mean this very cool
looking guitar support which doesn't use
suction cups but rather it uses these
clamps
and
i was really intrigued because since i
did have the experience where suction
cups come sometimes came off in the
middle of a concert and that was pretty
inconvenient i thought you know what
clamps could be the solution
so the wood side support has this pad
which is very flexible and this goes on
your
your thigh
there's a bit of
felt or some type of fabric there which
is grippy so that's really good then you
can kind of mess around with the the
width of these clamps here but it just
clamps on to the side of your guitar
once you've got the right
height so once you've got it clamped in
the right spot you can just prop it onto
your left thigh and then
find your
ideal position and then hopefully
there we go okay so i can let go but i
have to say i don't feel balanced yet
i would love to spend more time with the
support because you really need to play
around with you know where exactly does
it go moving it one inch to the left or
one inch to the right changes a lot
of course also changing the height of it
matters a lot and for the wood side
guitar support
you can get an extender which is what i
did which allows you to go higher which
is i definitely needed so this is with
the extender and for me it puts the
guitar
in more or less the right spot again i'd
have to play with it a little bit longer
now one of the first things i noticed
when i use the wood side support is that
there's tons of freedom
in your movement and that's because
there's a son of a swivel on here which
allows you to move without the point on
your thigh changing so it's swiveling
from the base and that's really
convenient and comfortable i feel like i
could move you know musically uh and um
still still feel supported um
i think that
with the freedom of movement comes a bit
of insecurity for me right now because
i'm not used to this device but this
could potentially be a really good
solution
especially if you feel kind of locked in
place
with another support device but like i
said at the moment i'm finding it a
little bit insecure
[Music]
another tip for everyone at home no
matter what support device you're using
if you're at all feeling like you're
insecure with your position of your
guitar or you feel like it's going to
slip you really need to do yourself the
favor of spending three to five dollars
at a hardware store and getting this
shelf liner um you can get one roll and
it'll last you a lifetime i usually get
black because it looks good on stage you
cut out a patch of it you put it on your
thigh below where the guitar goes
and that grippy material makes it so the
guitar isn't going anywhere so just a
minute ago i was feeling a bit insecure
with the gripper now i feel
really nice and i have also
the flexibility to move with the support
which is
pretty comfortable
depending on the sport you might also
put some gripper underneath support
that would also help you could also even
put it where your chest touches the
guitar there's so many different options
but you can't go wrong with some gripper
that's really useful
another great trick that i don't see
almost anyone utilizing
is to take advantage of these klingon
stabilizers these are this little static
electricity stabilizers you can take
them off the sheet
and basically all you do is you put them
on the instrument where the wood touches
your thigh a lot of my loots especially
i find this so useful because the loots
have a round back and they're famously
slippery
but you can put this also on your guitar
even again it doesn't hurt your guitar i
put it on right there
and then
you instantly have that extra grip and
you don't have to carry around a gripper
so
very useful
all right we have one more support
device today the biggest
the biggest of the day this is a really
cool look and support by the company
guitar lift also made in germany this
guitar lift
kind of struck me as
too big and bulky to carry around when i
first saw it and i didn't really know
what to expect
it uses suction cups like the ergo play
but i have to say i was blown away in
the first two seconds because there was
no assembly uh i just took it out of the
box
and i just put the
thing on my thigh there's kind of like a
foam pad where your thigh goes
i put it there i just held up the guitar
where i wanted it
and then from here you just lean the
guitar into the suction cups
and
let go
so i literally this thing arrived in a
package i opened the box i took it off
and i did that and in two seconds uh i
was holding the guitar where i wanted it
to go
so in terms of ease this beats all the
other devices you really can't go wrong
so uh i'm pretty impressed
there are four suction cups which go
against the wood and again don't worry
it doesn't hurt your instrument what i'm
noticing is that the guitar lift itself
is pretty heavy and so my guitar becomes
quite heavy uh even though it's a very
light instrument so i'm not sure how
much i like that although when you put
it against your your leg and it falls in
all that weight falls into your leg it
does feel very secure
so i think the major thing i left about
this support is that
it's super convenient easy to install
and i really don't even feel the need to
add a gripper because it's uh it's
really not going anywhere but it is a
suction cup device so so maybe one will
come off in the middle and you have to
lean against it so again i've only been
using this one and the wood side support
for a few weeks
but it's pretty impressive
[Music]
all right so we tried all these
different guitar supports which ones you
to go with
i think in the end
there's no perfect support there's no
one way to hold the guitar
they all have pros and they all have
cons
the table did support the instrument but
it was really terribly inconvenient
the strap is very convenient and cheap
and also you could even stand when you
play which is really nice but i have to
admit that when i wear a strap i
sometimes feel kind of straight jacket
kind of tied to my instrument and i i
can't move my body free from the
instrument so that's a con foot stools
are super portable they're easy to carry
around throw in your guitar case it's a
traditional way of holding the guitar
but i don't find it ergonomic the ergo
play is really convenient lightweight
super adjustable it puts the guitar
right where i want it
but sometimes the suction cups come off
the wood side guitar support was great
for flexibility of motion
but there was some assembly required and
to get exactly the right height uh took
a little bit of time and lastly the
guitar lift was like two seconds out of
the box i was in the right position but
it's quite heavy and like the like the
ergo play the suction cups can come off
so let me know what you thought
i'm sure a lot of you have experience
using some of these devices let's get a
good conversation in the comment section
going about your experience and what are
the pros and cons of the device that you
use
so thanks so much for watching i really
hope you guys found this video to be
useful and
if you like what i'm doing and you want
to help me make more videos like this
you can easily do so by becoming a
patron on patreon and by becoming a
patron you can also get lots of perks
like downloads of my cds mp3s of my
videos to listen on the go
behind the scenes content and a lot more
so
again thanks for watching and i'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
you